[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online
Demi Lovato definitely made Rihanna
proud to working to her debut single pon
de replay
during a recent workouts meanwhile flip
or flop star christina el Moussa has
been showing off the results of her hard
work in the gym on Instagram I'm doing
I'm doing really good I'm in a really
good place the kids are happy they're
healthy the mother of two also seems to
be in love with her new french bulldog
puppy
here she is smooching her new quote
boyfriend Kashi I like to work right I'd
rather work than sit at home it's a good
thing it seems we may have gotten a hint
about Sarah Paulsen's next big role
during Sunday's American Horror Story
Roanoke PaleyFest panel Paulson's
frequent collaborator Kathy Bates
repeatedly referred to her as the
people's princess a nickname given to
the late Princess Diana we don't know if
Bates was simply joking or teasing fans
but we do know Paulsen is confirmed for
the next season of feud which will
follow Prince Charles and Princess
Diana's tumultuous relationship
the internet went nuts after seeing this
commercial which originally aired in the
UK featuring Harry Styles and a cryptic
date April 7th which many fans believed
could mean he's releasing his debut
single
[Music]